Jerry Nadler now leveling threats and
placing a timeline on Robert Muller the
man he and the Democrats thought would
bring President Trump down saying a
subpoena is coming before the end of the
summer
joining me now saw Weisberg former
deputy independent counsel and a Fox
News contributor
along with Alan Dershowitz Harvard Law
professor emeritus and author of the
introduction to the published version of
the mother report Alan Democrats are
really pushing for Muller's testimony
but isn't it possible that the gops case
could actually be strengthened by his
appearance it's possible but there's no
legal right to molars testimony there's
no legal right to any of the Muller
report indeed even though I wrote the
introduction to the Muller report there
Muller report never should have been
written there's no room under our
Constitution for special counsel special
prosecutors reports prosecutors have the
right to say only one thing we have
concluded that there is no evidence
sufficient to charge the president with
Russian collusion or obstruction of
justice period I'm taking no questions
I'm making no public report I'm giving
my findings to the Attorney General no
prosecutor should ever go beyond that we
all agreed with that when Comey went
beyond that with Hillary Clinton I don't
understand the difference between the
criticism of Comey for saying that
Hillary Clinton engaged in extreme
carelessness everybody criticized that
and then we want to know why Muller
didn't charge the president it's the
same thing the whole enterprise of
special counsel special prosecutors is
inconsistent with the Constitution I
hope we've seen the last of it now Saul
you were watching John Dean's show
yesterday where he was testifying on the
hill and purporting to draw a connection
between the Watergate roadmap to
impeachment and what Muller's report
represents your thoughts first of all
they're completely different those two
roadmaps Jaworski and the grand jury
were very careful not to make any
arguments whatsoever not to draw any
conclusions they just said here is on
on March 17th 1973 President Nixon had a
conversation with these two people then
they listed the tape recordings and the
grand jury testimony that the house
could go look at totally different than
the Muller report which which made a
number of legal and factual conclusions
that's number one but number two more
importantly for the people who still
believe that firing James Comey could
ever be criminal obstruction of justice
the Watergate roadmap which was all
about obstruction of justice
right that's what the grand jury
indicted people for never in any way
dimensions right the firing of Archie
cops obstruction of justice and I've
looked at just about every book on
Watergate
I don't believe to were skis people ever
even thought about and diding but anyone
under an obstruction in theory for
firing Cox there is a precedent that's
much closer and of course nobody talked
about it yesterday and that's George HW
Bush pardoning Caspar Weinberger
pardoning the five people on the eve of
their trial the special prosecutor in
that case Lawrence Walsh said that was
designed to stop the investigation and
it did stop the investigation nobody
ever suggested obstruction of justice
against President Bush alright let's get
back to current day Sheila jackson-lee
was speaking today guys on the civil
contempt citations that are being
floated around for bar etc let's watch
we will see what we will do next if the
compliance continues then we'll take the
next action off the table but everything
still remains on the table until we know
that they have fully complied with the
information that we need
Allen is there anything there there
there's no there there there is no legal
obligation to provide the public or
Congress with any of the information
certainly not information that is
protected by grand jury secrecy that
involves ongoing investigations it
violates the separation of powers for
Congress to try to compel disclosure and
that the executive branch has the right
to maintain secrecy over not forever but
while there are pending investigations
and until a judge clears the grand jury
what they're actually asking bar to do
is violate the law and no court is going
to compel an attorney general to violate
the law
yeah Bar I should have referred to DOJ
not white House Counsel I was
referencing McGann trying to get him to
testify but that's the case is it not
saw again this idea that no compliance
has taken place when it seems like
they've gone overboard and I would argue
they gave up too much information the
executive branch during this process so
I'll close it out but not only that but
you know just think of the case of David
Simas worked for President Obama
he took the exact same position he would
not allow him to even come to Congress
it's a position being taken by every
president Democratic and Republican for
the last five administration all right
guys thanks so much